it has it has been going and it's a lot
of things but
it's just it's so slow right now yeah
it's crazy and then like you can kind of
start i bet and then it's you know
everything's back to nothing so it's
crazy
okay i think we're good all right all
right
um i will count us in um and thanks for
joining us david it's nice to have you
all right so this morning we have some
really good news for vegas entertainment
magic mike live really exciting news is
coming back to las vegas in march and we
have david terry with us one of the
performers
hi david how are you doing i'm good how
are you doing
good we're so happy to have you uh as
you can imagine a lot of people are
really excited the show's coming back
and it's gonna be kind of a new version
so excited too yeah tell us about it
what's gonna be different
so we have this brand new venue at the
sahara um
and it's gonna be kind of twice as big
as our last theater it's still gonna
be in 360 um that the stage was at the
hard rock
but um they're kind of implementing a
lot of new things into this show
uh it's going to be bigger better
they're taking kind of elements from
the london show the berlin show the
touring show in australia that's going
to be opening soon
um and they're they're kind of putting
it all in this theater and a lot of
these ideas into the show that we're
going to be
opening on march 26 next year um
so it's it's going to be fun there's
going to be for those of you who have
been to the show
it's going to be some of the same stuff
but then a lot of new elements as well
so we're really excited about it yeah
and david for people who
haven't been uh you know you guys do
so much in the show you have the show
you have you guys sing you're
you're an amazing singer you dance and
you guys have to obviously
work out a lot so what are you guys
gonna be doing from now till march
oh man yeah try i guess trying to get
ready uh trying to prep ourselves for
that for that
moment uh it's gonna sneak up on us
pretty quick so if you're not ready it's
uh it's gonna be rough
i know those rehearsals leading up to um
to the shows are gonna be rigorous and
our our bosses are
are very hard work crews and they expect
the same amount of us so
uh but we're we're ready to have some
fun we're ready to get back
into everything um as soon as it opens
so
but um yeah it's uh for those of you who
haven't been it is a combination
of a lot of things uh not only dancing
but we have acrobatics we have
um we have musicians um there's it's
kind of there's kind of
something for everybody there so um
there's this comedy
i don't think you'll be bored um you'll
you'll find something that you like
hopefully so
yeah i've never heard anyone leave magic
mike board david
good yeah at least at least not bored no
i also heard that your grandma
has been to the show yeah she has been
the show my
uh yes my 98 year old grandmother
uh came to the show i think was it it
was the first year that we were doing
the show
at the hard rock and and she she loved
it and i think
my my younger cousin was with her and
she asked she asked my grandmother
barbara she was like barbara would you
like what'd you think of the show and
and expecting kind of like a risque kind
of answer from her and she's like i'm
i'm 98 years old there isn't a lot i
haven't seen but she she had the best
time ever a lot of the guys
came over said hi to her she she loved
it
absolutely loved it so i was happy to
hear that but um
i placed her in a position where you
know she couldn't see me the entire time
which was
just preferred so i was okay with that
yeah you know i bet she had a blast
that's so exciting um anything else
david i mean
i know it's been a hard few months
especially for you guys for entertainers
um how excited are you to get back on
stage and just do what you do
best um yeah i'm
i mean i'm really excited to get back to
it
i know it's been really tough for a lot
of performers here in las vegas and
everybody's just kind of
keep trucking along and and doing
whatever they can to be creative
and um and i know that the team with
magic michael live
channing and the production team have
been really really adamant about
creating just an entirely new show
that's
that kind of goes above and beyond um
what it was
and kind of reinventing the show to
still be creative
i know a lot of people have concerns
about like with covet and everything but
they're
they've definitely they've definitely
figured out where
they're kind of going up above and
beyond the expectations of like
government guidelines in order to have
still like a safe
and fun show that you're still going to
have a blast at nothing's being like
taken away instead they're kind of
reinventing things in order for you to
see everything in kind of a new light
so i'm just really excited to get back
and
performing for people so make people
happy yeah and i know that new theater
it's
i think it's twice as big as the one
over at the hard rock so as a performer
that's so exciting you guys have more
room and i'm sure more um you know
you have more ability to do a lot more
with the show yes yeah it's it's it's
going to be great i'm very excited about
the new space at the sahara
so how exciting all right well everyone
has to wait till march so
until then thank you so much for being
with us we appreciate it thank you so
much
have a good thanksgiving all right you
too thank you
bye bye
yay i think that